my what is a woman College Tour
continues this week I'll be screening
the film at the University of Central
Florida tonight and then moving on to
the University of Houston now the
Houston event is apparently already
creating serious tension on campus as
the Houston ABC affiliate reports watch
ideas could reach a boiling point
Thursday at the University of Houston
controversial conservative Matt Walsh is
speaking and showing his new movie some
of the trans Community believe the film
is an attack on them because of this
they're planning their very own event
but as ABC 13's nicknoterio discovered
it's one of the conservative group
welcomes
a lot of eyes will be on this U of H
building Thursday night inside a speaker
brought by a conservative student group
will showcase a new film we believe as
college students on a college campus
that that view is the minority we
believe that a majority of students do
believe in genders do believe in the
difference between man and woman outside
protest is expected to take place this
is in my opinion not a freedom of speech
issue but rather a hate speech and a
safety issue the concern by some and the
trans Community is the topic of the
speaker Matt Walsh's movie It's called
what is a woman Walsh says it's a look
at the gender ideology movement trans
activists say it's a film that attacks
them and others who perform gender
reaffirming procedures Eden Rose Torres
who's a trans woman or is this film
could generate anger towards her
community I'm going to be extremely
worried about the students of University
of Houston the students and the faculty
I they do not deserve to feel this
unsafe and be put at this much risk now
I just want to clarify that when I have
described the film as a bombshell
documentary I didn't mean it literally
so you're not going to be getting any
physical danger whatsoever I promise you
also when I say that audiences have been
blown away and left stunned by the movie
um which is true these are also not
meant to be taken as actual physical
descriptions of their reactions these
are um metaphors and hopefully that will
put your your mind at ease so I suspect
that that's not the source of the
confusion here as we've covered when
they say unsafe they mean that their
understanding of the world and of
themselves is vulnerable when it's made
to confront contrary viewpoints so they
say unsafe but they mean really
destabilize their conception of reality
is fragile it's precariously at the top
of a stack of wholly unsupported and
arbitrary assertions and and
presuppositions
um they're terrified of anything that
threatens to knock the whole Tower over
that's what they mean
now there is something perhaps ironic
about this crippling fear on the left
given that the left scrape project is to
itself destabilize and Destroy knocking
over whatever it can topple so for a
good example of this we go elsewhere in
Florida to Allendale Methodist Church in
St Petersburg which recently played host
to a drag queen during Sunday services
and this video has gone viral the drag
queen goes by the stage name penny cost
obviously a sacrilegious play on the
sacred Christian holiday of Pentecost
but his real name is Isaac Simmons and
he's a candidate for ordination in the
United Methodist Church he's an
associate pastor he's also an atheist
who proclaims that the Bible and God are
quote nothing
Simmons makes these declarations in a
slam poetry performance posted to his
website where he proves that his
imitation of a poet is even less
convincing than his imitation of a woman
listen
look the Bible
the Bible is nothing nothing but poetry
pain and performance the Bible is no
more holy than Alan ginsberg's House of
life no more peaceful than Oscar Wilde's
requiesca and Pache and no more stronger
than Tammy
days
eyelash glue God themself
is no more tangible than the cacophony
of invisible butterflies floating in new
lovers stomachs yearning to be set free
from the bondage of past harm and the
lacks of rightful mistrust God themself
is nothing
but if she were she would be yes
cleaning her way down the runways of
Paris and Montreal strutting on that
tight rope pulled taught between
absurdity and opulence balancing between
too much and never enough
there's a lot of cheap blasphemy going
on there but let us not allow the
heretical nonsense to distract us from
the fact that the Poetry judged on its
own merits is extremely bad no more
tangible than the cacophony of
butterflies floating in new lovers
stomachs yearning to be set free this is
the kind of line that a student in a
community college creative writing class
might come up with and then hopefully be
expelled for right on the spot it's
cliche upon cliche if I were to if
utilize my own poetic metaphor I would
say that this guy has the intellectual
depth of an inflatable kiddie pool
tinted with urine and pockmarked with
dead beetles and horseflies floating on
the surface not exactly Shakespearean
either but at least it's a little bit
more descriptive in any case Isaac
Simmons of the atheist drag queen Pastor
showed up to perform to perform at a a
fake Church in Florida a few days ago
two young girls were brought up on the
satanic altar to be used as props for
this display and then this conversation
unfolded
do either of you have any questions for
Miss Pentecost
you like her eye shadow that's great
yeah
maybe she'll let you borrow it when
you're older when you're allowed to wear
makeup yeah of course
yeah well one of the things I think is
great about Miss Pentecost is she
reminds us that we we follow a God who
calls us to not conform to things of
this world uh that we're supposed to be
transformed by the renewal of our minds
and that means that what I think today
may have to change tomorrow if I
continue to renew my mind and it's so
cool that we serve a God that calls us
to continue to grow and continue to to
change into something new uh and to not
be bound by the ways that the world
confines us sometimes that we're
supposed to live differently
now the apostate preacher there is
referring to in hideously mangling
Romans 12 2 which indeed warns us
against conforming to things of this
world and calls for the renewal of our
minds this actually means in our in
context if you read the sentences before
and after it is that we must live in a
way that is quote holy and pleasing to
God and we must use quote sober judgment
and avoid falling into pride and
self-regard
we're told to conform ourselves to the
body of Christ love what is good and
hate what is evil that's what that's
what the whole verse says um the verse
in other words warns against
precisely the sort of display we just
witnessed drag is among other things
profane ostentatious self-focused
prideful absurd
it is anything but the product of
humility and sober judgment
it's the opposite of the verse that the
pastor uses to defend it and of course
most importantly
drag is not a rejection of the things of
this world it is a thing of this world
it's a product
of the decadence and moral Insanity of
modern American culture
it's hard to think of something that's
more of the world than that it's also a
a a trend and a marketing gimmick
it is all of the things that Romans
chapter 12 tells us to reject
but what the pretend pastor at the
pretend church is really trying to say
is that drag especially when mixed with
church or with children or with both at
the same time
is meant to break down barriers it's an
attempt to
um destroy or at least weaken cultural
guide rails and fences that have been
put in place
and that is certainly true this this is
all the left does after all
um except that the barriers the left
breaks down are barriers barriers of
basic human decency of um intellectual
and moral coherence of objective truth
it silences the voice of tradition tears
down all that was built by our ancestors
simply because it was built by our
ancestors therefore it must be bad they
reason
that's what drag is about it's what
gender ideology is about it's about
critical race theory is about
it's what everything on the left is
about
this is a sort of renewal that the
pastor was talking about
now people on the left they they might
even agree with most of my
characterization up to this point yes
they'll proudly Proclaim We are
fearlessly tearing down barriers and
we're we're claiming our independence
and our autonomy
because we're not conformists like the
rest of you
but what they leave out is that the old
barriers
you know those barriers that made sense
and which were rooted in natural law and
objective truth and uh Traditions
stretching back through the ages
they are not knocked down to reveal a
wider and Wilder landscape where people
are free to just Roam and do whatever
they want
no the old barriers are simply replaced
with new ones
and the new ones it turns out are far
more restricting and constricting
they're also arbitrary and
intellectually indefensible
so
the barrier which says that you should
you know you shouldn't include children
in your cross-dressing performance that
goes away for instance we're tearing
that one down
but a new one which says that you should
not show a popular documentary on a
college campus
is put in its place
so you can dress and drag and dance
around kids but you can't show a
documentary dealing with a serious
subject to a bunch of college students
all sorts of new restrictions are put in
place
new fences are built
the new ones are all tenuous they're all
fragile
they blow over in a slight breeze
and whenever they do a million screaming
harpies will burst into tears claiming
that if we don't respect these new
boundaries people will die
so what's the lesson here we leave the
old ways behind
but we're not Freer it turns out
far from it well I hope you enjoyed that
clip from Matt Walsh show if you did be
sure to subscribe to this YouTube
channel and click the notification
button to get more content like this if
you want to watch or have listened to
the full show head to dailywire.com And
subscribe today you can also listen to
my podcast on Spotify Apple podcast or
wherever you get your podcasts